- What is the problem here?
Are you embarrassed of me
because I'm a has-been?
Because you know that
I'm writing that book
that is gonna make
everybody love me again!
- You're not really writing a book.
- Well I already spent my
advance, so that's a first step.
- Look, this has been a lotta fun,
but I need to start
thinkin' about my future.
I mean, you don't even respect me enough
to have a baby with me.
- Whoa, what?
I never explicitly said that.
- You said it with your actions.
- What actions?
(horn honking)
- Oh, look at that baby!
Isn't he the cutest baby you ever saw?
- What, what, what?
(thudding)
No, no, what?
(car horn honking)
(glass shattering)
(engine revving)
(tires screeching)
(crashing)
(engine revving)
(tires screeching)
(crashing)
(sirens wailing)
- [Police Officer] Step away
from the stolen vehicle, sir!
- [BoJack] No, no,
misunderstanding, officer.
I was running away from my girlfriend
whom I don't respect
enough to have a baby with.
- Oh, face it, you're
afraid of commitment.
- I'm not afraid of commitment,
I commit to things all the time!
It's the following
through on that commitment
that I take issue with.
- Hey, stupid, isn't that
your friend over there?
- Ugh, Mr. Peanut Butter?
God, I hope he doesn't see us.
- Is that BoJack Horseman?
- Oh jeez, here we go.
- Mr. Peanut Butter and BoJack
Horseman in the same room.
What is this, a cross-over episode?
- You know, that gets funnier every time.
- You're being sarcastic,
but I think it does actually
get funnier every time.
- We're actually in the middle
of breaking up right now,
so if you could just...
- Yeah?
You're in the middle of it?
- Yeah, that's right.
- So would it be awkward
if I joined you right now?
- Yes actually, it's very
awkward, is that not clear?
- Yeah, this is awkward, right now?
- Yes, please leave.
- How are you, Mr. Peanut Butter?
- Ah, livin' the dream,
P.C., livin' the dream.
- Why are you making conversation?
- Oh, let's see, it's the English word.
It's called being polite, BoJack.
- But am I crazy that this is a bad time?
- Always a Clydesdale
never a Clyde, eh, BoJack?
- What?
- You'll get that one later, man.
Erica!
Get outta here with that...
- Would it kill you to be civil?
This is why we're breaking up.
- So it's not because of
the thing with the baby?
- It's because of a lotta things!
Waiter, could we please have the check?
Thank you.
- We haven't even ordered yet.
- I have wasted so many dinners
on you, BoJack Horseman.
I don't know how you can
expect anyone else to love you
when you so clearly hate yourself.
- Lemme see that.
(car horn honking)
$10 for bread?
(wings flapping)
I don't wanna live in a society
where the pre-meal bread isn't free.
- It is free if you order a meal.
- Can you take me home please?
- Yeah, but I didn't
even eat that much bread.
What did I have, I must've had...
- You ate nine baskets, sir.
- Nine, really?
Great, now I'm gonna feel
like a fat-ass all week!